chloé clem sont sur les routes d'indre
et loire
ils poursuivent leur découverte des tiny
house vient tout juste d'arriver chez à
l'historique habitent avec leurs deux
enfants dans la panique juste derrière
grande elle est vraiment différente de
celle de ce matin
du coup on a devant lui tant il
ressemble à l'inter
noé et alice sont ébéniste ils ont
construit eux mêmes leur mini maison sur
un châssis de semi remorques
alors voici la fameuse attaque pas si
tannique ça fait une petite quarantaine
de mètres carrés à l'intérieur bon voilà
on va rentrer ouais ok la récup de
palettes provisoire mais sa façon la
maison est presque terminée le couple a
travaillé dur pendant un an pour
aménager cette townhouse à leur image
donc le salon qui fait aussi à notre
chambre en fait et les bébés du coup les
plans de la thaï news vous avez prévu
vraiment pour votre style de vie que ce
soit exactement
oui la même par exemple ce meuble à la
le gros meubles jaune on l'avait chez
nous et en fait voulait pas s'en séparer
donc on a fait les plans autour parce
qu'il est et on continue ok alors du
coup là c'est la chambre là c'est la
cuisine donc elle présente des espaces
heures bal et ya beaucoup de volume
ouais c'est l'endroit le plus testé
voulait un espace à vivre pas trop pas
trop fermé parce qu'on a eu des enfants
donc ok puissent circuler un art fait du
vélo fait du vélo dans la nuit donc
c'est qu'elle a montré la chambre
du coup là ce sera à la chambre pour les
deux enfants ce serait quand même petits
lits superposés pour par contre quand
ils auront six sept ans ça va commencer
est un peu un peu petit pour eux on va
voir ça de voir si vous voulez mais je
crois que c'est la salle de bain la plus
impressionnante est super et je
m'attendais pas ce qui est on espaces
séparés pour les toilettes un vrai
espace toilettes et un vrai espace
douche douche baignoire franchement
table à langer machine à laver
magic n'a pas vu ce avait mis plus d'un
mois la construire les sans compter le
temps combien ça vous a coûté en
l'allégeant pour une taille et comme la
nôtre avec une finition comme comme nous
on a fait on sera aux alentours de 150
mille euros m'étouffer le tout fait et
ça m'arrive maintenant qu'on a vu une
belle tania russe de l'intérieur ça vous
a donné envie de vivre l'expérience nous
mêmes
du coup on va dormir dans une tanière ce
soir on vous dit à tout à l'heure